a new documentary podcast is out it's
called it was said sports featuring some
of the most important and inspirational
sports speeches throughout history folks
like muhammad ali billie jean king and
hank aaron it's written and directed by
noted historian john meacham but
narrated
and
uh i hosted i i think you one could say
by none other than the coach of the
philadelphia 76ers doc rivers who's back
here on the rich ozone show on the
mercedes-benz vans phone line how are
you doc
rich i am doing fantastic uh my bears
won last week yes uh the podcast is out
okay uh john meacham
everything's good
okay that's good so let's take this uh
one at a time we'll put a pin in the
bears and we'll pull that one later
um so so you now get to say what many
people in the world said including
myself is i have a podcast you get to
say these words now doc yeah those are
words i can tell you i never thought i
would ever say
i am uh you know i've never done
anything like this but john meacham
who if you don't know you should know
he's one of the great political writers
of our time
uh he actually wrote john uh
joe biden's uh acceptance speech
president biden's acceptance speech and
he called and said hey would you like to
do a podcast together and i'm thinking
an nba coach and a political writer
what do we have to talk about number one
and and can we pull this off i thought
it was just so interesting that i jumped
for it and i i've had a ball doing it
and so you spoke to al michaels urban
meyer stray michael strahan and so each
each one of these podcasts includes a
conversation based on a famous sports
speech
that you're pulling on some of the
threads at the from the speech of the
time and how it works today is that the
way that this works yeah really not only
just a speech but sports happenings like
um henry aaron uh chase uh to break babe
ruth's record you know talking to people
i tell you the dusty baker stuff is
absolutely unbelievable uh just what
hank aaron went through uh you know
muhammad ali and just you know what he
went through with not going uh to the
draft and going you know through his
career and what he stood for tim tebow's
speech you know the promise
uh and talking to tim and urban meyer uh
you know the first one came out last
week and that was the 911 jack buck if
you remember jack buck's speech you know
and and the role that sports plays in
that in society and it's bigger than
just sports sometimes so it's it's it's
been great i tell you for me
the interviews were great but doing the
readings for me i found them to be very
difficult now i have to say this
rich this is hard for me to say but i
have new respect for you
let me just say that because being a
narrator it's not easy it is not
learning i'm not seeing all the words
i'm a lazy talker after time but you
don't realize it until you have to read
stuff well plus you know i mean you
shoot your voice uh you know you shoot
it basically between november and you
know june right i mean so you just you
scream and you're yelling you got to
save your voice but your voice is
definitely distinct so uh what did you
learn doc i mean
that
did you interview dusty for for the hank
aaron episode is that yeah you know the
dusty stuff was really cool and and not
you know obviously
the pressure that that hank was under
but the pressure the whole team was
under
but to learn other stuff more like dusty
was talking about when they traveled uh
all you know all the black players no
matter what city they would go to you
know obviously they had problems eating
at restaurants and uh staying at hotels
but the stars of every team would invite
the other black players from the
opposing teams over to dinner he said
every trip you went on you would go over
someone else's house
uh and and have dinner uh and sit and
talk uh and not just the blackface it's
like so when they go to cincinnati pete
rose would invite them over
so it was just really interesting to see
the camaraderie that the sports had uh
back in in baseball uh some really neat
neat stuff tim tebow told her really
cool story about after he said the
speech he was in the elevator and
a bunch of reporters were in there but
he had his hood on they didn't know he
was in there and they were talking about
can you believe that guy said that
speech that was awful
no way no really well yeah it's just
really cool to hear all these guys and
all their stories did he take his hood
off and say my floor's here and just get
off and then press all the other buttons
and then run out to the elevator
that's free
you know as in tim tebow's way
that is not workers they got off first
and then he went right back up to the
locker room and said and went and start
working out that's what tim tebow would
do see that's it i'm more spiteful i'm
i'm a definitely more spiteful new
yorker uh doc rivers here on the rich
eisen show again the documentary it was
said sports uh with some terrific
stories some terrific speeches memory
lane stuff and then as doc just pointed
out make you smarter and you hear some
great stories season one launched on
september 8th new episodes available
wednesdays wherever you get your your
podcasts doc uh let's let's get to the
here now uh with with you and your team
and the woj bomb as it is said in our
profession about a conversation that ben
simmons reportedly had with the
franchise and you are part of said
franchise as the head coach that he
never intends to put on a sixers uniform
again is that what he told you doc
rivers well i didn't say it in that word
but it's so you know it's funny rich for
us it wasn't much of a bomb because we
already knew it but for the world it was
i guess the world that's being um making
us feel like we're a lot more important
than what we really are uh but for
sports fans it was um
but but that doesn't mean that's got to
happen rich you've been around sports
long enough guys i'm never coming back i
don't want to come back and then the
next thing you know they're back
and so
you know we don't take it lightly uh we
do understand
um the frustrations we understand
uh and you understand this when you're
in sports and uh you have your dream of
winning some and it doesn't happen for
you
uh the mental toll that that takes on
you and each individual and so
this has happened more than we know uh
then you know i would say
um
but
yeah so we don't take it lightly but we
intend to get them back and we wanted to
have them back well in terms of that doc
uh what did he say were the issues um
now uh some you know many of them are
completely obvious i mean the the fan's
reaction to his playoff series
um and of course him not dunking a ball
and passing it was sort of a microcosm
of of whatever potential problems he was
having or going through
what what i mean i think it's all that
but you know it's funny like that one
play got so much play and people forgot
that he did make a pass and uh matisse
got fouled matisse miss one made one
tree throw so that play was only it cost
one point
you know what i mean uh we didn't come
up empty on that play
uh having said that it's i'm not gonna
get into all the things um that that he
voiced
a lot of it was past stuff that um
you know happened years ago um obviously
the frustration on how
um you know just things
went doing the playoffs you know but one
of the things i kept reminding ben of
and i remind fans of is that trey young
was five for 24 in game seven
um he wasn't five for 24 because no one
was guarding him
he was five for 24 because ben garten
you know and ben has a value
rich um
to the team
that is not as obvious
as being a great scorer
you know it's so easy to look at a guy
at 30 points and you can equate that
value to the team it's very difficult to
see the value that ben wallace has or
dennis rodman has or charles oakley has
or ben simmons has
on the team because he doesn't score
uh as natural as some of the great guys
but he does so many other things for our
change
but what about the statement
that again this is one of the many
reasons why i'm bringing them up to you
is because these are what's being
discussed
uh in the media and certainly being
reported that your comment after game
seven when asked a direct question in
your postgame press conference of
whether
simmons could be a point guard on a
championship team
your response was i don't know how to
answer that right now and that is
apparently what he is so pissed about
but that's a great example and rich
we've known each other a long time yeah
i don't think i've ever said that's a
great example of the media misleading
something i'm saying okay but i'm gonna
say that and and i said that people
didn't even take it the next day
what i said was the guy it was the first
question after game seven
and i said exact words guys i'm not
answering that question i don't even
know how to answer that question right
now
um
i was answering the question not
about ben that i was saying that the
question was stupid
and so i'm not answering that
it had nothing to do with then and and
what was disappointing is
everyone on that call and that on that
zoom call cause that's what we do after
games yes knew that what that's what i
was talking about
and then the next day this thing takes
his own life
and you know me i don't get out and try
to i'm not gonna call people that's not
what i said um but i have the
opportunity to do it now and i'm doing
it um and it's obvious all you just go
back and play it um
what's been reported that i meant
wasn't true
um and i said it the next day
after that i said i absolutely believe
we can win a world championship with
benson
and just the last one on this subject
for you doc i mean you've been around uh
the block many many many times certainly
in the northeast
even if you and ben simmons or the
franchise and ben simmons that we can
can tend to get together and ben's
issues that he has can be bridged in the
same way look at uh green bay did with
rogers i mean it was the same thing
throughout the offseason he was a bears
fan i'm sure you were rooting for the
other result with rogers not showing
back up in green bay but you know it
can't happen what about him with the
fans it just seems that the fans and i i
that was my assessment ben simmons is a
terrific player but in philadelphia
he's maybe no longer a viable athlete
there
how how do you know how do you do that
i listen they i i protected been all
year as far as with the fans and
this crazy narrative somehow they have
about him uh vince terrific i know that
our players know that uh and but the
only way to quiet the fans is we have to
win and and
that's
but you know listen i don't want to get
too dramatic here but isn't that what
makes sports great like every year
every year you know chris webber's
speech in the hall of fame uh was
phenomenal because he talked about not
ever winning a title
but having the opportunity every year
each year after i don't win the title to
come back and lace my shoes up and try
to do it again and answer the critics
and face the fire uh and put yourself
out there that's what makes sports so
great because when you actually are able
to pull it off you realize two things
how hard it was is the one thing which i
don't think people appreciate how hard
it is to win and and so uh and then the
second thing is that you can face the
fire and go through it and that's what
makes it great so yeah that's the only
way to quiet them uh rich is by winning
so where does everything stand right now
what's your game plan here uh if it is
in fact true as part of the wodge bomb
that
that that there's been no communication
since since he told you his intention to
stay away from training camp
well there's been no communication over
the last couple of weeks
but we still talked to his agent
several players still talk to up to ben
um you know i always look at you know
you use aaron rodgers as an example i i
remember that this first trading sean
elliott you know and the physical film
he said i'll never play again there um
he comes back
and they win the title together so as
you know and i know things can change
but we just got to keep communicating
and getting through to them and maybe we
can change and then the other part of it
is ben does have a four-year deal so
this is all really in the team's hands
on what we want to do
and we're just going to do what we feel
is right for the team and i think that's
the most important part then that is to
keep ben simmons right now yeah okay
right now doc river's here on the rich
eisen show do you think justin field
should be starting what do you think
what do you think i'm on that side
i trust the coach i trust coach maggie
you know i don't want justin fields to
get out there and get hurt um
from lack of blocking
um
but i do love him i think he's going to
be an excellent quarterback sometimes we
have to be patient um
in this world is that a word anymore
patience yeah
you know no i i'm i know it's just you
know
the concept of take your lumps now and
you know can can get you where you need
to go faster you know you take a look at
justin herbert year two if if he had sat
last year
you know he'd be taking his lumps now
just that whole concept obviously you
just don't know how the lump taking can
actually leave in a permanent mark
literally
or or or stunt the growth that's that's
obviously the case and you know justin
herbert is more of a fallback
quarterback where fields are so athletic
and runs um you know i think he would
actually take more lumps let's say so
you know i love the bears it's my team
um
i'm frustrated not really with the
coaching it's um more sometimes with
our our picking process let's just say
that uh
and so
uh i feel like he's in good hands so
we're all podcasts can be acquired right
now um everybody should check it out
some fascinating stuff from speeches and
discussions and interviews with doc
rivers and uh that that one with urban
meyer and and uh tim tebow were they
together did you get them together
were you separately separate that would
have been phenomenal but i did get them
separated same day and what was great is
you could tell they've been together for
so long right each one told the same
story a couple of times without the
other one being there and i was like wow
these guys are really tied together
doc thanks for the time really
appreciate it uh at doc rivers on
twitter and of course this documentary
podcast called it was said sports were
all podcasts can it be acquired new
episodes available on wednesday episode
one is already out don't go anywhere uh
without it was said sports in your phone
doc thanks for the time
thanks rich tell suzie i said hi i will
do that that by the way those are her
favorite words in the history of this
show i'll be honest with you
until susie i said hi from the guys doc
rivers right here on the rich eisen show
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here